Good morning, Jacob. It's Saturday, April eleventh, twenty twenty-six, in
Jefferson City. And Artemis Two is home. The crew climbed
out of the capsule in the Pacific last night —
eight oh seven P-M Eastern, about forty to fifty miles
off San Diego. Wiseman, Glover, Koch, and Hansen, all healthy,
all recovered cleanly by the U-S-S John P. Murtha. Nine-day
mission. Distance record broken on the way out. First crewed
lunar mission since Apollo Seventeen in December of nineteen seventy-two.
Fifty-three and a half years. The thing that was supposed
to happen actually happened, and it's worth letting that register
for half a second before the rest of the world
piles back in. It's eighty-three degrees and sunny in Jefferson
City today. Mostly sunny, light southeast wind, shifting southwest. Low
around forty-six tonight. This is genuinely the best day of
the year so far. If you spend it indoors, you'll
regret it. Now, the calendar. The Google Calendar A-P-I is
still returning ancient events — same failure as yesterday. So
I'm treating today as an open Saturday. By context: the
Pinwheels of Possibilities resource fair is on the South Capitol
Lawn from ten A-M to noon — Child Abuse Prevention
Month event, three blocks from home. And the U-S-Iran talks
open in Islamabad all day today. You don't have a
role in this, but it's what the news cycle will
orbit. Speaking of Islamabad. Vance is on the ground with
Steve Witkoff and Jared Kushner. The Iranian delegation is already
there — Foreign Minister Abbas Araghchi and parliament speaker Mohammad
Bagher Ghalibaf. This is the first formal session of the
highest-level U-S-Iran talks since the nineteen seventy-nine Islamic Revolution, which
is a sentence that should cause a brief moment of
vertigo if you stop to take it in. Three things
to actually watch today: the joint readout — if nothing
by tomorrow morning, the first session didn't go well. The
Lebanon language — whether Lebanon is mentioned at all in
any official statement. And the Hormuz tolls — if they
get addressed, it's real diplomacy. If they don't, it's theater.
The Atlantic's Will Gottsegen has the counter-consensus take worth absorbing:
Iran walks into Islamabad with structural leverage. They control the
Strait of Hormuz. Hezbollah is a free escalation option. The
U-S political clock is running faster than theirs. Manifold agrees
— the market for a second Iran ceasefire in twenty
twenty-six jumped from forty-one percent to seventy-five percent overnight. Traders
are saying this one won't hold. Now, the Mythos cascade.
Chapter two. Three things in the last thirty-six hours paint
a picture of Anthropic under real pressure. One: an OpenAI
researcher's Reddit post that his Anthropic roommate, quote, lost his
mind over Mythos. Two: Stella Laurenzo, A-M-D's Director of A-I,
filed a detailed GitHub issue on April second documenting Claude
Code degradation across nearly seven thousand sessions. She found thinking
depth dropped roughly sixty-seven percent after Anthropic deployed thinking content
redaction in early March. Her team has already switched to
another provider. Three: Anthropic is now banning users under eighteen
via Yoti third-party age verification, with manual review of chat
histories. Read these together and the picture is: strained internal
culture, public quality critique from a peer company's A-I director,
and defensive policy tightening. None of this should change your
decision to apply for the Sales role — if anything,
a company in this posture needs more, not fewer, competent
operators with government-procurement chops. Project Glasswing is now officially on
anthropic dot com. The partner list is broader than the
early leaks suggested: A-W-S, Apple, Broadcom, Cisco, CrowdStrike, Google, JPMorgan
Chase, the Linux Foundation, Microsoft, NVIDIA, and Palo Alto Networks.
That's the entire American cyber-industrial establishment in one coalition. Anthropic
is committing one hundred million dollars in Mythos Preview credits
plus four million in open-source security donations. A ninety-day public
report is promised for early July. The absent name is
the one you'd expect most: Meta. And the hard data
on the war premium is finally in. March C-P-I came
in at three point three percent, up from two point
four in February. Energy costs plus ten point nine percent.
Gasoline plus twenty-one point two percent — the biggest monthly
jump on record. Core inflation was only plus point two,
so this is entirely the Hormuz-Brent shock showing up in
the headline number. It makes the Fed's second-half rate-cut thesis
materially harder. Quick hits. The D-C Circuit declined to block
the Pentagon's supply-chain-risk label on Anthropic — the same label
creating friction for your Claude pilot at Budget and Planning.
France launched a government Linux desktop plan — nineteen thousand
upvotes on r slash technology, digital sovereignty framing. Tesla is
in its eighth consecutive week of losses, JPMorgan warns sixty
percent downside. Sam Altman's home was targeted with a Molotov
cocktail — no injuries, suspect arrested, but the A-I backlash
narrative now has a physical-violence dimension. Apple Q one numbers
are quietly great: Mac shipments plus nine percent, and Apple
led global smartphone shipments for the first time in Q
one with twenty-one percent share. Alright. Here's the thing. Yesterday,
Katelyn green-lit the Anthropic application. Explicitly. The Apple Note titled
Why Anthropic, asterisk, on your phone was last touched Thursday
morning with an asterisk you added yourself. Katelyn said yes.
The weather is perfect. You know what today is for.
The activation energy work is done. Today is a first
draft, not a finished masterpiece. Write it by noon, and
you can spend the rest of the day outside without
a single voice in your head telling you you should
be doing something else. Artemis Two is home. The Capitol
dome is still blue for Child Abuse Prevention Month. Islamabad
is talking. And you have a cover letter to finish.
That's your briefing. Go outside at some point.